[Laughter]  i would be so irritated if my opponent  did that to me  the difference on their faces you know  just the emotion you've got one  agony and one is in ecstasy  it's  yeah it's incredible i mean if duda had  seen that smiling gary  he would have been so angry  you think what he's like  i think it should be a gif yeah don't  you think yeah or an nft oh  yeah  yeah what a moment for a niche still  smiling  he is saving this game and they uh  finish in a draw there it is wow look at  that smile on a niche gary's face he is  so happy he saves the draw in a lost  position and uh that means they are  still tied these two after two games in  their quarter final match  game three coming up in  15 minutes young christophe duda is not  happy  he blundered away the win in this game  and he's looking over it  the game they now have 15 minutes uh to  rest and prepare for game three where a  niche will have the white pieces but  what a game and here is today's lisa  vetta learning points